we've got breaking news this morning
president joe biden is no longer
promising as he had been to shut down
the coronavirus the white house has
announced a major change in strategy and
it will focus now not on shutting it
down
but on
beating it back
are you no longer going to shut it down
no we got to beat it back before we shut
it down look it's going to take time
worldwide in order to beat covert we
have to shut it down worldwide we've got
to beat it back for analysis of this new
strategy we turn now to dj paulie d from
the jersey shore
we're beating up the beat that's what we
say when we're doing our fist pump first
we start off banging the ground we're
banging it as the beat builds because
that beats hitting us so we're fighting
back it's like we beat up that beat you
got to beat it back you got to beat it
beat it back and beat up that beat we
can only hope that the ruling class will
have more success at beating it back
than it has at shutting it down
or stopping the spread or flattening the
curve or any of the other constantly
changing euphemisms that have been used
to justify the continuous and indefinite
reordering of our rights
society and way of life i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on friday is from reality who
says do i place a gucci order directly
with blm or one of their car trunk
retailers in the shopping mall parking
lot actually either one it doesn't
matter the only
retail source that has not been affected
by the supply chain
is the
black market for stolen handbags and
sneakers and television sets and all the
other things that came out of the mostly
peaceful protests from 2020. that that
is so either way and don't worry you can
get it in time for christmas you know
when you want to get a higher end gift
for christmas the right way i would
strongly recommend you check out the
parole source pearls make a great
christmas gift one of the most timeless
classic christmas gifts you can possibly
buy something that for instance
i bought for my wife last year well at
the pearl source you get the highest
quality pearl jewelry at up to 70 off
retail prices
at the pearl source you will find the
largest selection of pearls available
anywhere and each jewelry piece is
custom made specifically
for you with global supply chain
problems and shipping carriers expecting
major delays as you get closer to
christmas
now is the time to get started shopping
for the christmas season do not wait get
those presents underneath the tree the
pearl source offers fast and free
two-day shipping on every order with
zero contact delivery everything comes
beautifully packaged in an elegant
jewelry box so it's ready to be given as
a gift not sure if she will love your
gift well no worries the pearl source
comes with a no hassle 60 day money back
guarantee with free return shipping
totally risk-free right now our
listeners can get 20 off your entire
order do not wait until it's too late to
do your christmas shopping go to the
parole source the pearlsource.com
knowles enter promo code knowles at
checkout for 20 off your entire order if
you want find pearl jewelry at the best
prices go straight to the source the
pearlsource.com knowles enter promo code
knowles at checkout gonna beat back got
to beat it back
got to beat it back and only once you
beat it back can you shut it down and
slow the spread and stop the
flattening and the and the curving and
you know you're not fully vaccinated
right i know that many of you are have
not had any of the shots or you know the
most important shot in the history of
the world but but even even those of you
who have even those of you who have
gotten
one shot there was the one vaccine that
was one shot and then there's the the
other vaccines the mrna vaccines were
two shots and then there was a booster
so then that would be three shots
but even even those of you who have
stuck yourself with the fauciachi three
times
very soon may not be considered fully
vaccinated
israel right now
is considering authorizing a fourth
covid booster shot
to
immunocompromised citizens
one of the true buzzwords of 2020. the
immunocompromised
will will potentially get a fourth
booster shot according to this report
from channel 12 in israel health
officials will discuss this uh this
possibility of the fourth shot because
of the new worrying omicron virus
variant rather
from which not a single person has yet
died but they're gonna now administer
this fourth shot
and uh it may well be the case that
unless you have four
four fouchy ouchies
you are not fully vaccinated but i'm
sure they'll stop there right that'll be
the end of it
of the vaccine that's so super duper
effective that you need to stick
yourself with it every two to three
months
four is the limit right we're not just
going to be back here in three months
and they're going to talk about the
fifth one because of the phi beta kappa
variant right right now where it's over
because we'll have beat it back and shut
it down and flatten the curve or
whatever the next one
is going to be
some people don't want to stick
themselves with the fouchy aochie
a tremendous headline from the new york
post
really in keeping with that paper's
already excellent headline writing and
the story itself is terrific
italian man wears fake arm in crazy
attempt to avoid getting kovit 19 jab an
italian man
not an italian-american man but an
italian man
bought a a prosthetic arm
and
affixed it to himself and somehow hid
his own arm
and
and then went into a vaccine clinic
to try to get a shot injected into the
plastic so that he doesn't have to get
the fauciachi into his own blood but can
get the green pass without which you're
not allowed to do basically anything in
italy right now
apparently the craziest part of the
story is at first it worked
so he rolled up his sleeve and it just
looked like an arm and so the nurse was
about to do it and then when she grabbed
the arm she felt there was something a
little weird about it and then asked him
to remove his shirt and then she saw it
was a fake
it was a fake arm great stuff
classic
classic example of the italians doing
whatever they can to avoid the rules
gotta love it
the real story here though is about the
vaccine and the virus
if the vaccine
were as desirable as the ruling class
insists
you you would not see this kind of
resistance
right because everyone would want it
you would not see people
putting on fake arms to try to avoid the
punishments associated with not getting
it and you would not see the kind of
crass inducements to getting it like
bill de blasio stuffing his face with
cheeseburgers saying get the shot pigs
and then you'll get more slop we'll get
you cheeseburgers and french fries
right you wouldn't you wouldn't see
lotteries in ohio saying if you get the
shot you'll get a million dollars
possibly well i thought the shot was so
great so why do why do you need to bribe
me in order to get it if
if the vaccine were quite as desirable
as as the ruling class says it is but
for that to be the case the virus would
have to be as dangerous as the ruling
classes told us it is and it manifestly
is not even according to the cdc and
even according to the fda
if you contract
the virus your odds of dying from that
virus are extraordinarily low and when
you take older people out of the
equation when you take people with lots
of health problems out of the equation
the already low odds
drop dramatically they become
extraordinarily small
and so people a lot of people the vast
majority of people look at the virus
they say it's not that dangerous and
they look at the vaccine they say it's
not that desirable i don't protect
against the virus it's not not
doesn't pose a grave threat to me
probably not going to do it even
trevor noah trevor noah is the host of
the daily show ever since jon stewart
left
trevor noah is a huge lib but trevor
noah came out
and he said you know we seem to be in
kind of a weird rush to produce all
these vaccines and make everybody take
the vaccines maybe there are some
misaligned incentives here
so on the one hand
almost all the omicron cases have been
mild so far
but on the other hand
the guy who stands to gain millions of
dollars from new vaccines
says we need new vaccines
huh if we don't make a new vaccine this
disease could be with us ferrari i mean
forever sorry i was thinking of
something else now look i'm not saying
that the ceo of madonna is lying i'm not
saying that at all i'm just saying i
don't think he's the most objective
source on this topic
of course not
of course not
and it's becoming even clearer as the
omicron variant appears to be much less
deadly than the other variants that we
had seen before we don't know it's still
new but
the
insistence that we must have an even
newer vaccine from people who stand to
gain a lot in terms of power and money
if if everyone has to get a new vaccine
it just seems like the incentives are
misaligned and that's why this
issue of the growing public health rule
of this country the suspension of the
ordinary constitutional order
the insistence that we all take this
experimental shot
is i think it's less about left and
right though it does you know the right
generally is a little more resistant to
it the right the left rather generally
is a little more open to it but it's
it's less about left and right than it
is about incentives and the ruling class
and even trevor noah
over there on his show on comedy central
his left-wing show even he
is recognizing that speaking of
dishonesty in public health
uh mary margaret olahan from daily
signal went out to that big
march that was going on in washington dc
all the all the big protests
as the oral arguments were heard in the
dobbs pro-life case and she just went
out and asked
the people who were marching hey what do
you think is going to happen if roe gets
overturned listen to
the terror in these women's voices
what does our country look like if roe v
wade is overturned um
i'm gonna start crying women will die
women will die
we're out here today at the united
states supreme court where justices are
hearing oral arguments about one of the
most pivotal abortion cases of our
lifetime we'll be asking protesters on
both sides of the aisle what our country
would look like without roe v wade let's
go see what they have to say it'll look
like women going to jail a lot of women
will die
or they will be forced into a life of
poverty a lot of women are telling me
that women will die if rove is
overturned i think that's happening
already it's really scary because it
puts a lot of people in immediate
physical danger
and i just don't want to see that happen
a lot of people say women will die if
rose overturned oh yeah it's it's it's
happening already well hold on wait row
hasn't been overturned yet so you're so
you're telling me that wrote getting
overturned actually won't change no uh
hold on never mind erase that i went a
little too far a lot of women are going
to die though
shows you the power of
narrative because a lot of people
believe this and it's just not true the
the
year before roe versus wade was decided
32 women died from illegal abortions
1972.
19 women died in 1973.
24 women died from legal abortions in
1972.
25 women died
from legal abortions in 1973 it actually
went up for the legal abortions both all
four of those numbers extraordinarily
small not thirty nine thousand not
thirty nine hundred not three hundred
ninety thirty nine or twenty four
and when you look at states where it was
legal and illegal actually
you had a greater you you had about the
same risk from illegal and legal
abortions the reality very different
from the narrative
just like you see in the grocery store
when the narrative says this product is
made in america very often it's not
that's why you got to check out good
ranchers you know that mariah carey song
oh it's of course you know it it's you
can't go into any store for
any time from september until february
without hearing it but
she says all i want for christmas is you
all i want for christmas is meat i want
nice delicious red meat and i want it
from the good ranchers good rancherous
baby they have 100 american meat that is
steakhouse quality goodranchers.com has
a variety of boxes to give or to try for
yourself this season you know giving to
a numero uno over here choose the
rancher's classic for the perfect combo
of high quality beef and tender chicken
or go with the cowboy to have the
ultimate steakhouse experience with
black angus ribeye's wagyu burgers and
more i for me look they're all delicious
i would go for the ladder i would go all
for the red meat it is so so good
especially their burgers get all your
individual incorporate gifts at good
ranchers today
give a gift they will remember for years
to come get your goodrancher's box or
gift card today tis the season for open
hearts and full stomachs so give good
ranchers with code noles for 20 bucks
off in free shipping goodranchers.com
knowles or use codenoles at checkout to
take advantage of this special christmas
offer give a gift they'll remember give
good ranchers if you go around
and ask
liberal women or liberal men for that
matter hey what's going to happen if roe
v wade gets overturned you're going to
hear
5 000 women a year are going to die at
least maybe ten thousand women a year
are going to die from back alley coat
hanger abortions just like was happening
before roe versus wade saved all those
women's lives
none of that's true that those numbers
were completely made up actually the man
who made them up dr bernard nathanson he
was one of the leaders of naral the
abortion rights league he admitted this
because he became a pro-lifer he said we
pulled that number out of thin air you
can see the cdc data you can see what
these women were actually the numbers at
which they were dying from legal and
illegal abortion
it was in the low double digits
and that was 50 years ago imagine how
low it would be
now
it's just not true but
if you
to give
these pro-abortion people
get a little bit of sympathy if you
really believed that overturning roe
versus wait was going to lead to 10 000
women every year dying in back alleys
desperate women dying bleeding out in
the alleyway
you might be more reluctant to overturn
it even though it's unconstitutional
even though it's evil even though it's
resulted in a genocide of 60 million
babies since roe v wade
you you say i don't want 10 000 women
dying a year
but
good news buddy
that didn't that's never happened
in my modern history you haven't seen
that happen and it wouldn't happen
if roe v wade were overturned but
there's a lot of ignorance going around
and when we want the peak
examples of ignorance where do we turn
we turn to
those cackling hens on the view that's
where that's if you want ignorance tune
in to the view and if you're trying to
find the height of ignorance there where
do you turn
joy behar so joy behar one of the hosts
on the view
uh just reacting to the potential of
road being overturned expressed her
belief that the what's really at the
heart of this debate
is
the unwillingness of conservatives to
accept the consequences of sex
if you watch america which i like to
watch america and i watch television a
lot it's a very interesting schism that
goes on here because on the one hand
sex sells everywhere i mean you can't
see an aspirin commercial without
somebody having sex you cannot turn on
any program especially on streaming
where people are having this
there's soft porn everywhere now they
encourage all of that it sells
everything sex sells and yet when it
comes to the reality of pregnancy
this particular group of people on the
right in this country and these
religious zealots do not understand the
reality of what happens when you have
sex it's almost like they don't want to
see that part they just want to see the
fun in the bed
not the second part
siri what is projection
oh it's there it is okay it's right
there okay you just okay we don't need
to play it again that's fine
what is
conservatives
don't understand the realities of what
happens when you have sex says joy
behour does that sound right to you
it's all these conservatives saying like
hey yes screw whoever you want yeah free
love man go on out nothing bad will
happen
don't get married and settle down and be
monogamous and be faithful to your
spouse just go and do whatever with
whoever and it's tot is that that's what
the conservatives say or
that's what the american left has been
saying incessantly
for at least 50 years
oh it's the latter
no but but michael the
the netflix and the movie studios and
hollywood and the media they have all
these images of casual sex oh right
hollywood famously controlled by
conservatives right all those movie
studios and television networks and and
and streaming platforms that are
famously controlled by the american
right uh doesn't sound
familiar to me the entire thing is
controlled by the left two things going
on here one it's this
uh classical example of an american
leftist particularly one of a certain
age
who believes that it's the conservatives
who control the institutions when in
fact american conservatives do not
control a single institution we don't
even have the military anymore none of
them hollywood the universities the
administrative state the elected
government the military all of it is
controlled by the libs
right so
if the establishment is pushing out a
message it ain't coming from the right
okay it's coming from the left
furthermore
furthermore
the conservatives who are saying hey
maybe you don't have sex
casually hey maybe you should get
married hey maybe marriage has a meaning
hey maybe
do you think they're saying that because
they don't know what happens when you
have sex
or because they know exactly what
happens when you have sex
and
the
the projection here the fact that joy
behar is getting it exactly wrong the
fact that the american left doesn't want
to face the consequences of sex is at
the heart of abortion because
the the left first pushed
casual sex
and
as a result of casual sex sometimes
babies are made so then they had to push
contraception everywhere this is why you
see condoms everywhere now and they're
being passed out in public schools and
and all the rest of it
but sometimes condoms don't work
sometimes birth control doesn't this is
why they're trying to push for
subsidized
contraceptive pills but sometimes they
don't work and when you when you take
these sorts of things and you encourage
promiscuous sex just at scale you're
going to have more unintended
pregnancies and so in order to protect
the divine institution
the
sacrilegious view you know that that uh
casual sex is a divine institution then
you've got to have abortion
to stop the breakthrough cases and
that's what this is really about this is
about
the american left which believes that
you ought to be able to pursue your own
will and your own basis desires
unimpeded and any anything that gets in
the way of that like perhaps
or especially a little baby has to be
done away with
and you heard her there you heard joy
bears these religious fanatics
who think we shouldn't kill babies these
wow you must be part of some esoteric
crazy kooky cult religion if you think
it's not a good idea to kill babies or
that maybe we shouldn't sleep with
everybody every single person that we
come in contact with
you're gonna see a lot more religious
bigotry of this sort there was there was
a cartoon in the washington post over
the weekend
headline adjudicating while catholic
there was a woman
walking past two bathrooms at the
supreme court one bathroom said men
the other bathroom said incubators
and that was the women's room and the
woman was pregnant so men and incubators
you see these catholics they only view
women
as mothers they think that women have
this special role as mothers and the
producers of life and they think this
has value and that's just so wrong
that's so they don't think that women's
highest calling is to do spreadsheets at
the widget factory like men do these
awful
catholics
these patriarchal
so
a lot of conservatives who saw this
cartoon are decrying the religious
intolerance and the bigotry and the
outright anti-catholic bigotry and
that's true obviously it's a very
anti-catholic
cartoon and newspaper and
establishment and american left i mean
this is the kind of place where the
current president has sued nuns okay and
the guy he worked for last time sued
nuns so barack obama so
that exists
but
let's be fair here
we are going to have some view we are
every single
nation has religious views
throughout all of history and for all
the rest of history that will
necessarily be the case
to give an example one of the views our
country's founded on is that we are
created by our creator we are endowed
with certain unalienable rights among
which are life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness that is a religious view
and
if you disagree with that religious view
then then your views are going to be
suppressed in america
at least traditionally that has been the
case
if you believe that human life is worth
protecting that's a religious view and
it means you can't have abortion
that innocent human life is worth
protecting obviously you can deal with
criminals that's kind of a different
conversation
but certainly if you believe human life
has some kind of worth you can't just be
killing willy-nilly innocent little
babies without due process without a
trial right you can't be doing that
if you think that human life does not
have intrinsic worth and that we just
kind of give human life worth depending
on how the rest of society feels then
perhaps abortion is acceptable that's
also a religious view but you're gonna
have to pick one
and
inasmuch as leftism and liberalism are
on the rise
catholicism specifically christianity
broadly is going to be suppressed
inasmuch as christianity
broadly and catholicism specifically is
on the rise
leftism is going to be suppressed
and i don't think we should kid
ourselves about that there is no
neutrality there's no neutral playing
ground where radical leftist ball
worshipping child sacrificers which is
what abortion advocates are
where they and people who want to defend
innocent human life can just kind of
play in a totally totally neutral
playing field
where all of the constitutional and
legal and ethical and moral principles
are equally fair to both of them it's
just not going to be the case all right
and i think rather than playing to
maintain the status quo we ought to play
to win
when you want to win
when you want your company to win you
got to check out ziprecruiter did you
know that there are over 10 million job
openings but
only 7.6 million unemployed job seekers
great situation for workers not a great
situation for employers the issue is
getting worse and worse because of a
mismatch of employers and qualified
talent so employers are having to go
above and beyond to entice people to
want to work for them they're offering
things like pet insurance
or providing discount programs if you
can relate to any of these challenges of
growing your team then you need to try
ziprecruiter right now you can try
ziprecruiter for free at
suprecruiter.com knowles ziprecruiter
uses powerful technology to find and
match the right candidates with your job
then it's not just spaghetti at the wall
it proactively presents these candidates
to you
you can very easily review the
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply for your job which
encourages them to apply faster the
technology is so effective that four out
of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day right now you can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address ziprecruiter.com knowles kwles
that is ziprecruiter.com canadawlas
ziprecruiter the smartest way to hire
also
you might you might have heard on
thursday joe biden announced his winter
covid plan
not only did joe biden announce that
he's extending the federal mass mandate
for public transportation
but jensaki admitted that the
administration is considering requiring
americans to be fully vaccinated in
order to fly domestically this is why
our lawsuit against joe biden's vaccine
mandate for private employers is so
important we need to stop it before it
grows all right and we need your help
head on over to dailywire.com do not
comply to add your name to our petition
we need to send an overwhelming message
to this administration that the american
people will not comply with this madness
sign the petition please
dailywire.com do not comply then share
our petition with all your friends and
family let's send a message to the biden
administration that is so loud that they
can't ignore us we'll be right back with
a lot more
speaking of the media
fredo cuomo
has just been put out on his fishing
boat on that lake
all right that scene in the godfather
part two it just played out for mr chris
cuomo from cnn
not only
has he been indefinitely suspended
that's what happened last week at cnn
over the weekend it was announced
fredo has been fired
he's gone
say it ain't so afraid fredo
fredo sleeps with the fishes
they announced
they announced first at cnn that they
had hired an outside law firm to review
information about exactly how chris
cuomo helped his brother to navigate his
brother's political scandals
then
they
discovered allegations and
rumors and they said we're not bringing
chris back he's gone
my thought on this is
a little sympathetic to chris cuomo
actually probably more sympathetic than
most conservatives are but
still pretty gleeful
there's an old saying about grand juries
they say grand jury could indict a ham
sandwich
meaning
if you want to get somebody if you want
to get them and
even on a legal matter but if you want
to get their reputation if you want to
destroy their career if you want to get
them you can do it
everybody's got something everybody's
got a pass this is a fallen world you
can and
if you can't dig up a really good dirt
you can always trump up some dirt you
can you can really amplify it so you can
get them you can get people
in a way that's what's going on here
there is no new information about chris
cuomo
no new information really has come to
light why was he fired
chris cuomo was fired
ostensibly because
he
was supposed to be a tv journalist
but actually he was working as a
political operative to help his brother
this was the shocking revelation that
the outside law firm investigating
discovered was that chris cuomo
whose father and brother were both
democrat governors of new york chris
cuomo
might have kind of been a political
operative oh my stop the presses you're
kidding me
yeah duh
chris cuomo was not totally honest oh
you're telling me chris cuomo the guy
who pretended to quarantine from covid
in the hamptons and then filmed a big
special on cnn where he was coming out
of quarantine and seeing his wife and
kids for the first time but then we
later found out lied about that whole
thing was actually going on bike rides
in the hamptons and was not it was just
completely lying on tv and everyone at
cnn knew it
that guy might not be totally honest
oh wow oh my gosh you don't say
this is such bs cnn deserves absolutely
no credit for this firing
cnn is covering their derrieres is
what's going on no new information came
out
chris cuomo is simply no longer useful
to them
mario cuomo dead
andrew cuomo chased out of office run
out of town on a rail chris cuomo fired
what we are witnessing here is not some
new journalistic scandal we are
witnessing the fall of a political house
the house of cuomo there are political
houses in america the kennedys the
bushes the clintons
and
the cuomos
mario was a leading
contender to run for president he was
they called him hamlet on the hudson
because he couldn't decide whether or
not to do it and eventually he decided
not to but he would have been a big
contender mario actually to tie it in
with that abortion story mario is the
politician who popularized this idea
that you can be privately against
abortion but publicly support abortion
it was a way to let nominally catholic
politicians off the hook because their
real religion was leftism so they all
supported abortion but they had to try
to reconcile this with their public
performance that they were catholic so
they'd say well personally i'm opposed
to the genocide of babies but publicly
it's totally fine let's do it
and then his you know his son lit up
freedom tower pink to celebrate a law
that would permit abortion up until the
moment of birth
that's what we're watching we're
watching the fall of a political house
that's a wonderful thing that ought to
be celebrated but cnn deserves
absolutely no credit they're acting like
cowards they are at least as dishonest
and corrupt as chris cuomo probably much
much more so
establishment democrats are having a
very
hard
time these days joe biden
desperately trying to salvage his
approval rating
the approval rating of his entire
administration
is bragging heading into christmas about
how he's bringing down the price of oil
and gas
this worldwide effort we're leading
won't solve the problem of high gas
prices overnight
but over the last month
likely due in part to the anticipation
of this action
we've seen oil and gas prices out of the
wells
oil and gas prices on the wholesale
market come down significantly
all right i have two very different
thoughts so the first one let's just
deal with what he's saying first he's
saying oil and gas are coming down
significantly you remember the
democratic congressional campaign
committee posted a graph last week
bragging about how they've brought down
the price of gas
by two cents
since joe biden took office gas has gone
up by more than a dollar
but they brought it down last week by
two cents so now they're saying wow
great job joe significantly
see one cent that wouldn't have been
very significant but two cents that's
double that wow
great job joe my second thought this is
completely unrelated
what was that voice
can we play that clip again this
worldwide effort we're leading okay
let's solve the problem high gas prices
what who is that i know i'm i'm watching
the clip i know if you're listening to
it right now you might you might just be
saying is that the guy who does the
movie trailers
in a world where gas is
only seven dollars a gallon one
president will make it seven dollars and
two cents a gallon but that i'm looking
it looks like joe biden but he's got
this weird voice he's insisting it's
just a cold
it's not kovid there's nothing wrong
with his health
but
he doesn't he does not sound great he
does not sound like he's doing very well
and it would appear that his physical
problems are a symbol of his political
problems more broadly he just had his
physical and the doctor said the guy is
having trouble walking okay and everyone
knows it and it's putting them in a bad
position for 2024 because a lot of
people doubt that joe biden can run
again including most members of his own
party
uh kamala harris's approval rating is
even lower than joe's joe's at 38
percent commonly 27 percent
the the next best guy joe can look to in
his administration is pete bootage edge
pete buddha judge is also at 38
so he's much higher than
all the other cabinet secretaries but
it's still extremely
extremely low
and what they're trying to do now is
tell you no everything's great don't
believe your lying eyes gas prices are
going down everything is totally cool
speaking of gaslighting there was a
heritage foundation expert cara
frederick who was just testifying on
capitol hill
to
to explain some
numbers okay to explain
a fact of big tech and social media that
we all know to be true but that the
establishment is lying about right and
what we know to be true is that big tech
is censoring conservatives but every
time we bring this up and we point to
specific examples we say what about the
hunter biden laptop story right before
the 2020 election there was a major
story that would have seriously damaged
joe biden and it was completely true and
big tech would not let anyone post it
and they wouldn't even let you privately
message it that's obviously
tilting the scales in favor of the dems
hurting conservatives they'll say no
it's your imagination it's not real
i think we're not we're not censoring
conservatives well
take a listen to her analysis
twitter and facebook censor republican
members of congress at a rate of 53 to 1
compared to democrats twitter suspends
conservatives 21 times more often than
liberals
facebook created two internal tools in
the aftermath of trump's 2016 victory
that suppressed right-wing content media
traffic and reach on its platform google
stifled conservative leaning outlets
like the daily caller breitbart and the
federalist during the 2020 election
season with breitbart search visibility
shrinking by 99 percent compared to the
2016 election cycle and these practices
have distinct political effects
the media research center found in 2020
that one in six biden voters claimed
they would have modified their vote had
they been aware of information that was
actively suppressed by tech companies 52
percent of americans believe social
media suppression of the hunter biden
laptop story constituted election
interference
these practices erode our culture of
free speech
chill open discourse and engender
self-censorship
of course that's the case we all know it
to be true it's helpful sometimes to see
these numbers
you know the breitbart search visibility
decreasing 99
between election cycles that can't
possibly be entirely organic
so it's good to see that
but what are we going to do about it
are we going to
just you know try build our own facebook
are we going to just change the culture
you know just build your own
institutions well we should okay we can
do that too we can try to do that but
are we gonna have the courage to use
political power to punish our political
enemies
and to punish the people who are taking
an undue amount of influence in our
politics
people like
facebook and google and twitter are we
willing to we the people use our
political authority to say no you don't
get to control speech in a democratic
republic
you handful of silicon valley leftist
billionaires you don't have the power to
do that you don't have the legitimate
power to do that we're going to take
that power back and we're going to do
that by breaking up your companies and
by taking away your special legal
protections and by casting you into the
outer darkness where there's wailing and
gnashing of teeth what are we gonna are
we willing to use legitimate
political authority or not i'll give you
an example of strange standards
you remember there was a story of a very
sad high school shooting in oxford
michigan
that took place
a couple of weeks ago so the prosecutor
there karen mcdonald
has not just filed charges against the
school shooter obviously
but is now filing involuntary
manslaughter charges against the
shooter's parents
based on the information and evidence i
have received today i'm announcing
charges against the shooter's parents
jennifer and james crumbly
the charges are as follows
james crumbly
is charged with four counts of
involuntary manslaughter
jennifer crumbly is also charged with
four counts of involuntary manslaughter
i will now
publish the details that led to that
decision and have already previously
been made public which allows me to
comment on them in a swear to that had
just taken place in the district court
so why would the parents be charged with
manslaughter they they obviously they
didn't show up to the school and start
shooting people well because they they
failed to secure their gun and so their
deranged kid got the gun and went in and
shot people and killed some people
the parents right now
are being held in jail on a one million
dollar bond this is exceedingly rare
that parents that
would be held would would be charged at
all and then held in jail
for having a gun that a kid was able to
get access to if the kid then went and
used the gun exceedingly rare but the
parents are now arrested and they're
being held on one million dollar bond
obviously
the shooter should be prosecuted to the
fullest extent of the law
it seems to me what we're seeing with
the parents is a little bit arbitrary
and i'll give you an example why there
was another school shooting in texas
that you almost certainly have not heard
about you may have heard about it on
this show maybe in a couple of other
conservative outlets but you wouldn't
have heard about it on cnn or
washington post or new york times or any
of the establishment media outlets there
was a kid who showed up to school and
shot a bunch of people
he injured four people three students
and one teacher
and
not only were his parents not arrested
and not held on a one million dollar
bond
but
he was not held on a on a half you know
it was half a million dollars for one
parent half a million dollars for the
other parent and half a million dollars
for the shooter in this case even even
this kid was not held
on a half million dollar buy he was held
on a 75 000 bond and then they paid it
and he was released to his home with the
parents who were not arrested
now this texas student
was
was
not really made a cause celeb because
it would seem to me it doesn't follow
the narrative the narrative is that
deranged white kids show up and shoot up
schools
and so you know and and this is not even
just about the kids it's about the guns
and we've got to go take the guns from
people and take away their second
amendment rights but this kid was black
and so he didn't fit the media narrative
and so the media
suppressed the story they don't want to
talk about it they're not even going to
make it a gun case it's not the this
narrative is not as useful to them still
a school shooting thankfully no one died
here though a lot of people were shot
but that story is not as useful to them
so they're going to play that one down
and the
the other awful school shooting that one
that one they're going to play up and
they're not even going to make it
they're not even going to make it about
the people who perpetrated the crimes
they're going to make it about the guns
and your rights and pushing a narrative
and they're going to make it as
sensationalist as they possibly can in
order to do that which is why you're
seeing these extraordinary measures like
locking up
the parents
speaking of locking people up
there's there's this nation over in
europe i don't know if you've heard of
it it it finds itself in trouble
sometimes
this would be the nation
of germany now look i love my german
friends i love our many german viewers
but the nation of germany
some has had some problems over the
years
okay as as nor macdonald said you know i
don't know if you're all a history buffs
you know the issues of well obviously
the 20th century before that they you
know invented communism and there's some
issues well now germany
is going to lock down only its
unvaccinated citizens
germany is now announcing that if you
are not vaccinated if you have not taken
the fouchy algae
you basically just can't
participate in culture quote
culture and leisure nationwide will be
open only to those who have been
vaccinated or recovered from covid
this from angela merkel the outgoing
chancellor according to the telegraph
under the new measures
people who have not taken
this experimental drug will be banned
from restaurants and bars movie theaters
gyms non-essential shops and christmas
markets
both the outgoing and incoming
chancellors have voiced support for
mandatory vaccinations in a proposal
that would have to be voted through
parliament according to cnn
maybe germany should sit this one out
uh look i'm not i so hate
nazi comparisons so i'm not i'm not
doing it i'm not actually doing a nazi
comparison i'm just saying
if your
nation has a kind of checkered political
past and forget even much further back
than the nazis
you know maybe you err on the side of
caution and and this is really what a
lot of the debate over the vaccines and
the lockdowns comes down to
what do we mean by caution
everybody in the whole covid debate
thinks that he is erring on the side of
caution
the libs who want to lock everyone down
and put us all in a penal colony or
or a quarantine camp like they're doing
in australia they're airing on the side
of
physical caution
right public safety caution
conservatives
who recognize that the lockdowns have
not been all that great for our country
and the masks you know have been the
messaging has been a little incoherent
let's say on the masks and the vaccines
the goalposts seem to move every single
day
the conservatives are airing on the side
of
political caution
right
what the libs are saying like andrew
cuomo said in new york if my measures
save even this is not how endocroma
actually talks about if my measures save
even one life it will have been worth it
one life well okay his measures killed
thousands of senior citizens but he
thought it was just to save one life
right if we lock everyone down take away
all their rights take away all their
freedoms take away their whole way of
life
if it saves one life it will be worth it
and the conservatives are saying no if
you
if you completely destroy our political
order
so that some people don't catch the wu
flu that actually won't be worth it
so what side is it seems to me that a
place like germany ought to air on the
side of political
caution just as we all should
speaking of
fascists i don't know
nazis and communists and political
radicals of all stripes
there was a very scary
insurrectionist nation-threatening march
in washington dc over the weekend
you might have seen it trending on
twitter this was the march of the
patriot front so-called
a group allegedly of fascists and white
supremacists and they marched through dc
and the media oh they had a field day
and they said this is
the white supremacist takeover of
america and you can't really see who any
of these people are
and they're wearing masks and they're
marching they've got flags some of the
flags are upside down to signal distress
and
my first reaction
was that this was fed picnic part two
you know do you remember there was the
justice for january sixth rally and the
only people who showed up were feds and
media
and like one right-wing dude who didn't
get the memo that it was all fake
and so
i that was my first reaction was look
i'm
on the american right i spend a lot of
time in the american right i
i've been in it for a long time i'm
familiar with lots of fringe groups okay
even the ones that are way out there i'm
at least familiar with them i've never
heard of this group have you the patriot
front of the white supremacist national
whatever
no
so was it a fed thing or what or is it
real i don't know maybe it's real
even assuming for a second
that this is a real group
and there aren't any feds and it's not
fake and not just a media contrivance
ask yourself this what
what poses a bigger risk to you
a bunch of
clowns marching through the streets not
harming anybody
making a big show and giving the media a
circus but not
not burning down any stores or killing
people or assaulting people just kind of
marching
marching around and going home
probably back to quantico or
langley or something but you know
whatever what does that pose
the big bigger threat to you or does say
uh blm and antifa with the support of
the entire media and elected democrats
for six months burning down the country
does that pose the bigger threat
what's the real threat here because
according to the establishment blm which
killed dozens of people and torched
cities around the country and stole a
lot of gucci handbags
blm was mostly peaceful and according to
the media those guys whose identities we
don't know conveniently
those guys marching peacefully for a few
hours they are an insurrectionist threat
to destroy the country
obviously
the narrative seems a little bit
backward
now before we go
before there's so much more i want to
talk about but before we go
i've got to bid a fond farewell to bob
dole a lot of people especially the
younger viewers of this program and
listeners to this program might not even
know who bob dole is
bob dole was the republican nominee for
president in 1996
he was a vice presidential nominee with
jerry ford decades before that he was a
senator for a very long time he was a
war hero in world war ii he's the first
presidential candidate i ever supported
i've told the story on the show a few
times i was six years old i don't know
maybe my grandpa told me that bill was
great he was a war hero and clinton's a
draft dodger and i just really liked him
told all my first grade classmates to
get their parents to vote for it begged
my mother who wanted to vote for clinton
to vote for dole she let me go into the
booth and pull the lever
is that election fraud i don't know
you're not allowed to say there's any
election fraud so i guess it wasn't uh
dole great american one one aspect of
his courage that does not get enough
credit
obviously he was a huge war hero and
just a great american service country a
little moderate on some political issues
but he had a deep abiding
conservatism to him really and uh he
showed up to the rnc in 2016 and he
didn't trash trump and he didn't
he supported
he supported the party
at crucial moments at really moments
that required a lot of courage and
principle when a lot of squishes and
libs and selfish people did not and they
wouldn't show up to the convention they
wouldn't vote and i just think
that's a good thing he's bob dole saw
the bigger picture he's a good guy he
wasn't it's not like he just loved trump
and was always effusive toward trump
quite quite the opposite sometimes but
he was he saw the bigger picture he saw
what was good for the country
god god bless bob dole may his soul rest
in peace
we will see you guys tomorrow i'm
michael knowles it's the michael knowles
show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our new show morning wire on
today's episode new revelations from the
gelane maxwell trial a crime wave rocks
california and new york city is set to
allow non-citizens to vote in local
elections
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire